would you say
one nice thing about trump no
nothing zero i don't think there is any
good thing there's nothing you could say
more people think that trump is more
outspoken he cares for his his kids i
guess
trump is consistent in being
trump he's consistently trump
uh melania's pretty melania's pretty i
would agree with that
i would say the nicest thing i could say
about trump is that i
appreciate the change that he made that
allows people the right to try
i don't think i have one um the economy
is doing well
okay how about you um i do agree
with some of the criminal justice reform
policies that he has
supported i think he tries hard but his
motives are just
not what a normal american would
think is moral
uh i think he has great stage presence
like he is definitely a showman you know
as a business owner
i think you know he did pretty good on
you know like tax cuts so
i like trump because i think he is
realistic about certain
things in the economy i like the way
he's uh
i think i like his policies regarding
trade in terms of china
i like that he says the way he feels
that's what's on his sleeve
seems sincere he's unified the
democratic party
say one nice thing about joe biden uh i
think
i think joe biden is trying to take
things in a different direction so i'm
not completely against that
biting let me see i think you have a lot
of support
um i think joe has done his time and i
think he tried to help in 47 years
probably he tried and i i
wish him all in his retirement one nice
thing
uh he's worked for the united states of
america for a long time
one nice thing about joe biden he's a
sensible man
joe biden has been you know a loyal
american for
what 79 years and and uh
i mean he's presidential um he's figured
out how to do this for a very long time
which has secured his personal
fortune as far as biden i feel like he's
just uh
you get that more down-to-earth
realistic feel from him he's a nice guy
he seems to be a straight shooter too
i just want uniformity and stability
and just low stress
one nice thing about trump one nice
thing about biden they can kiss ma
they can both kiss her ass that's the
nice thing good for you guys
you